كانت [موسيقى]
لأكثر من 500 عام في
مدينة فلورنسا الإيطالية
كرمز للقوة والجمال الشاب
مايكل أنجلو ديفيد الشخصية التوراتية البطولية
في مواجهة جالوت العملاق
على مدار العام الماضي بأحدث
التقنيات  تم استخدامه لصنع
النسخة المتماثلة الأكثر أصالة التي
تم تصنيعها على الإطلاق من الكاميرات عالية الدقة التي تمسح
التمثال الرخامي الذي يبلغ طوله 17 قدمًا
بحثًا عن جميع خصائصه الدقيقة وتفاصيله ،
ثم كانت أكبر طابعة ثلاثية الأبعاد في العالم
تعمل ،
لقد كان تحديًا كبيرًا حقًا
قررنا استخدام التكنولوجيا
للمستقبل ، هذا هو طابعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
، ولهذا كان من الصعب العثور على
طابعة
قادرة على طباعة قطع كبيرة في النهاية
قمنا بتقسيمها إلى 14 قطعة
وكان علينا إعادة تجميعها معًا
بتكلفة تزيد عن 360 ألف
دولار والنتيجة هي 17  - نسخة طبق الأصل كاملة
مع شقوق
تلطيخ وسحجات وحتى غبار الرخام
المصنوع من راتينج الأكريليك ، يزن 10
مرات أقل من الأصلي
الشهر الماضي ، سافر ديفيد الرقمي الجديد
أكثر من
4000 كيلو  تم الكشف عن عدد الكيلومترات إلى دبي الذي تم
كشف النقاب عنه في
الجناح الإيطالي لمعرض إكسبو 2020.
إكسبو هو سلسلة حدودية إنه مكان
في العالم
حيث سيبدأ العالم الجديد بعد الجائحة ،
لذا فهو نقطة مثالية
في العالم لإظهار الرؤية
للنهضة
إلى التعافي  بالنسبة إلى هذه الشركات الناشئة الجديدة في حياتنا ،
فإن وجوده يكتسب أهمية أكبر
في فلورنسا
التي تضرر قطاع السياحة فيها
بسبب الوباء الجائحة
ملايين الأشخاص القادمين إلى
معرض إكسبو دبي 2020 ، وأنا متأكد من أنهم يرغبون
في زيارة فلورنسا على الفور
لمعرفة حقيقة
سيقف تاريخ ديفيد ديجيتال ديفيد أمام
الجمهور خلال معرض إكسبو 2020 لمدة ستة أشهر
من أكتوبر ،
ومصيرها بعد ذلك غير معروف
آنا ستيوارت سي إن إن